the direct path
if your awareness
does not already bring you
awe
reflect on why it does not
how does you being aware
you being conscious
in this reality
not create
a waterfall of awe
sentience is it
awareness is it consciousness
is it
in order for you to
fully realize
you must first focus
your awareness
this means come to a full
stop
take a break
and give the direct path your
full awareness
be in a setting that is
optimally conducive
to your realization
preferably be alone
be sitting comfortably
and be in a space that does not
have much noise pollution if any
at all
now that you're settled
as many of you know the breath is a very
powerful tool
to focus awareness
become conscious of
your breath of your inhalations
and exhalations
focus your awareness on only the
inhalations and the exhalations
do not let the monkey mind
take control and wander you around
stay focused with your awareness
on inhalation and exhalation
stay focused
keep your awareness on the breath
now that we've become more sensitive
with a more focused awareness
we can proceed
to recognizing it
so i would like
for you to undergo the process
of realizing
the difference between
awareness
in its most primal
is ness
and contrast that with
awareness when it is engrossed
enthralled occupied
by objects
by emotions by feelings by
thinking
let's call that coloration
so we're juxtaposing
awareness without
coloration with
awareness with coloration
ultimately this
juxtaposition is transcended but for
now we need to recognize this
it helps us with
realization
now slowly move
your awareness
more and more towards
the most primal awareness
awareness without coloration
and rest in that
every time that you bring your awareness
from coloration
back to awareness
without coloration
you are working
the muscle
of awareness reflecting on its own
existence
now you can see
if awareness spends
decades of life never
reflecting on its own existence
it will be difficult for awareness
to do said process
do not beat yourself up
if this is not landing right away
again recognize awareness
in its most primal state without
coloration
and juxtapose that with awareness
that is colored with feeling
emotion thinking
objects
okay
now you've recognized it it
is awareness in its most primal
form awareness without coloration
that is step two recognizing it
now step three
once you've recognized
what you truly are
which is this awareness
this sentience
this consciousness
this is
this beingness
this is it
you are it
this very most primal
awareness this most
pre-coloration awareness
is it
that is why you are it
i am it we are it
you are source i am
source we are source
we are that
i and my father are one
tatvam asi
wadat al-wujud
the brahmin the tao
you are it
that primal awareness that awareness
precoloration that sentience
that consciousness that beingness that
very
is ness is it
we are it expressing itself
and this is just one of many expressions
of it
step four abiding as it
this is the atma vichara this is
the self-abiding this is
when you've clearly recognized it
you've clearly recognized that you are
it and now
you work that muscle you work that
muscle
you do lots of repetitions until it
becomes your home
once it becomes your home
everything else downstream unfolds
at the highest possible morality
this abiding process
for some people is very short and for
some people is very long
see how often you can
call yourself back to that most
primal awareness
and practice that process
step 5 clearing your channel
as you abide as
it this
channel of being
begins expressing itself at the
absolute highest morality
it takes time
to identify the areas
in your beingness
that are like knots in a garden hose
clear those knots
many of us are familiar with those knots
the ego
self-dealing tendencies
anger frustration
disgust shame
guilt
the lowest of the low are knots
inside of us clear your channel
clear those knots in the garden hose
so that you can more and more purely
become a vessel for source
for it for god
butterfly effecting out the highest
morality
six express from it
naturally as your channel clears
you express
intuitively at the
highest levels of being
you have imperturbable peace
you have causeless joy
everything is for the highest
every way you express yourself
whether that be through business
entrepreneurship
whether that be through art
whether that be through engineering or
science
whether that be through music politics
civic engagement
ecology
however you express yourself
will be from the purest
from the highest
as long as you realize
that you are it
because once you realize that you are
it in seven
you realize that others
are it
your entire being becomes
in service to others
sir this
sincere service genuine
service authentic loving
compassionate and wise service
be of highest service
to the creation
and that comes naturally from
self-realization
from realization that you are it that
sentience is
it that consciousness is it that
awareness
is it
we are it expressing itself
and number eight creation is it
becomes more and more anchored
it becomes anchored in the body
the gnosis of the knowledge
the veda becomes anchored
within
and when your essence
realizes that creation is it that we
are it
that everything that is apparently
exterior of your
awareness is it
we realize the unity of all being in
existence
we recognize the oneness we recognize
the ocean we recognize
the sky and then we begin to recognize
the thoughts the emotions the feelings
and the objects
as clouds in that sky
another analogy is we recognize
ourselves we recognize and realize
that awareness as the screen
and we recognize thoughts feelings
emotions
objects on that screen
that appear and disappear
that's when you got it that's when you
know you have it
that's when you've realized when you be
when you are from there always
when you be from there always
and that leads to nine infinity is
it
this creation
is beautiful it's perfect and there is
no lack
the forces are perfectly influx
to create a harmonic
artistic expression
of
source expressing itself and
experiencing
that expression
yet this is but one expression
of source
when we leverage our imagination
when we leverage our intuition when we
leverage our
faith when we leverage those faculties
and we begin
accessing what exists beyond
this creation
that's when we begin accessing more
and more of infinity
because there are many creations
there are infinite creations
infinite ways for source to
express itself and to experience
those expressions
imagine
beyond these vehicles of sentience
these vehicles of sentience have two
eyes
they have four limbs they are
carbon-based
dna encoded
now take your imagination and run wild
what other vehicles of sentience
can you imagine
take a moment to reflect on what
other vehicles of sentience you can
imagine
everything that you're imagining is
beautiful
and source is expressing that
source is expressing all
vehicles of sentience all creation
designs
infinitely eternally immersing itself
inside of those creations
to experience them and that is what this
is that is what we are
and that's when number 10 the one
infinite creator
lands it is recognized
and it becomes you you become
it it's a marriage
and there's no divorce once you know
you know and once you know
you teach
because that's the best thing that you
can do
the best thing that you can do is to
pass along
the direct path
to other sentient agents
and to have them undergo self
realization
i congratulate those
that have underwent
advancements in their self-realization
if it's been a complete realization
congratulations
and welcome continue abiding
for those that made it a couple rungs up
the ladder
listen to this again
practice this process
create that juxtaposition between
primal pre-coloration
awareness and
awareness with coloration
of objects thoughts feelings emotions
and reside reside
abide in that awareness pre-coloration
and recognize that that is it that
sentience
that consciousness that beingness that
is-ness
is it
and you will realize
you will pierce the veil
and you will find the diamond necklace
that is already around your neck
you